>> Mike: JEFF PAUL IN TEXAS.
THANK YOU, JEFF.
OF THE LATEST EXAMPLES OF
VIOLENCE AGAINST RELIGIOUS GROUP
AND A PRESIDENT TRUMP CALLED
ANTI-SEMITISM A EVIL SCOURGE.
SECRETARY MIKE POMPEO SAID IT'S
TRAGIC AND UNACCEPTABLE FOR ANY
NATION TO PERSECUTE FOR
RELIGIOUS BELIEFS.
CORRESPONDENT JULIAN TURNER
LOOKS AT THE GROWING AND
DISTURBING TREND.
>> IN THE WAKE OF THE ATTACK,
JEWISH LEADERS ARE RINGING ALARM
BELLS UP AT THE RISE IN
ANTI-SEMITISM AND NOT JUST IN
NEW YORK STATE AT BUT
NATIONWIDE.
>> THERE'S A UNDERCURRENT OF
ANTI-SEMITISM AND THERE HAS BEEN
FOR SOME TIME, AND FOR WHATEVER
REASON USING IT MORE PREVALENT
IN OUT IN THE OPEN.
IT'S SCARY AND OF IS A VERY SAD.
>> 2019 HAS SEEN THE ALARMING
1,347 AND TAGS TARGETING OUT
ACROSS THE UNITED STATES DATES
DATES.
IT'S NOT THE NUMBER OF TAX THAT
ARE CAUSED FOR CONCERNS.
>> WERE LOOKING FOR THE UPWARD
TRENDS IN ASSAULTS AND THE MORE
SEVERE OF THE INSTANCES THAT WE
TRACK, AND THAT'S WHERE WE'RE
WORRIED AND IT'S CLIMBING UP THE
PYRAMID OF HATE.
WE NEED TO PUT A STOP TO IT AND
STOP IT AND ENOUGH IS ENOUGH.
>> THIS WEAKENS A TAG PROMPTED
PRESIDENT TRUMP TO ANNOUNCE WHAT
HE CALLS THE EVIL SCOURGE OF
ANTI-SEMITISM.
HE CRANED THAT ANTI-SEMITISM IS
ON THE RISE IN AMERICA AND BEING
STOKED BY PRESIDENT TRUMP.
HE ACCUSED THE PRESIDENT OF
IGNITING VIOLENCE TWEETING "HE
FUELS PEOPLE'S ANGER AND
MISGUIDED HATE."
THE SECRETARY OF STATE
MIKE POMPEO CAME TO THOSE
PRESIDENTS DEFENSE TELLING
FOX NEWS RELIGIOUS PERSECUTION
IS A TOP-TIER PRIORITY FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION AND HAS BEEN FROM
DAY ONE.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP MADE OF TRUE
PILLAR OF AMERICAN'S FOREIGN
POLICY RELIGIOUS RELIGION AND
FOR EACH OF US TO PRACTICE OUR
FAITH READING >>
IT'S NOT JUST JUDAISM THAT'S
UNDER ATTACK.
>> WE ALL OBSERVED CHRISTIANS
UNDER THREAT IN THE MIDDLE EAST.
AND OTHER PARTS OF THE WORLD AS
WELL.
AT SOME LENGTH ABOUT IN CHINA
HOW PERSECUTING OVER 1 MILLION
MUSLIMS.
>> THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION OF
VIOLATORS OF RELIGIOUS FREEDOM
AROUND THE WORLD ARE CURRENTLY
INCLUDING CHINA, IRAN,
NORTH KOREA, SAUDI ARABIA.
>> LOOKING AHEAD 2020, THEY ARE
STILL WORKING ON A NEW POLICY
THEY SAID WOULD MAKE AMERICA
FOREIGN AID WITH HOW THEY TREAT